from characters that we thought were
dead to monsters that even geralt of
rivia hasn't seen before season two of
the witcher raises even more questions
than it answers
perhaps one of the biggest plot threads
hanging in the balance at the end of
season two is that of the wild hunt
these wraiths were mentioned multiple
times throughout the season and geralt
jennifer and siri caught a frighteningly
up-close glimpse of the death riders
during the final moments of the season
when they were transported to another
sphere by series magic but the question
remains who are these omens of death and
why do they want siri well siri's elder
blood is apparently important to many
factions by the time the climactic
finale rolls its credits and that's why
the wild hunt are in pursuit but more
importantly who are the members of this
gas leak crew while they might seem
mysterious to us
geralt understands their nature to a
degree as he tells vesimir that he's
taking siri away from karamorin to stay
ahead of these otherworldly enemies
siri's power is eldritch an arcane
stemming from her elven lineage of
course she has little understanding of
her abilities and her grandmother queen
kalanthi did nothing to enlighten her
she is referred to as a source one with
magnitudes of power beyond mere mages
but has no control over it as a result
siri has mistakenly drawn creatures
through mysterious monoliths like the
one she fractured in the first season
when confronted by kahir outside of
sintra even with his encyclopedic
knowledge of countless species their
anatomy and their weakness geralt has no
knowledge of the new creatures that have
emerged from these monoliths gods
what is it i've never seen anything like
it
but geralt has stated that the wild hunt
and the deathless mother were from other
spheres with the implication that these
are alternate worlds or universes
at the battle of saturn hill we see
vilgefort's treachery when we witness
him sink a mace into a northern
colleague instantly this makes the
conniving mage a traitor but to what end
well in the second season vilgefortz is
vying for a seat on the council in
aratuza together with tesea the two make
a compelling team and it's revealed that
they now share an intimate relationship
tris returns to aratuza and tells to say
of series significance and then tasaya
betrays her confidence sharing this info
with vilgefortz upon learning of siri
vilgefortz is adamant that she is
pursued ultimately the brotherhood puts
a bounty on her head and on anyone
attempting to protect her vilgefortz
clearly has a hidden allegiance or
agenda but it remains to be seen what
the full scope of his intentions are as
he seemingly manipulates his colleagues
to his own ends
for a time siri was so in awe of
geralt's prowess in the realm of rooting
out and defeating monsters that she
became hell-bent on becoming a witcher
herself the only problem with that idea
is that the formula for creating the
witcher mutagen had been destroyed long
ago rendering them incapable of making
more witchers however when tris reveals
that siri has elder blood vesimir's hope
is renewed he asks siri's permission to
begin creating the mutagen once again
siri agrees on one condition she gets
the first taste while becoming a witcher
requires vigorous training the most
crucial element is the mutation they
undergo that refines their senses
reflexes and strength unfortunately most
witcher candidates die during the trial
of the grasses the process of receiving
the alchemical concoction to undergo the
necessary changes siri is willing to
take the risk but geralt is not he stops
her from making perhaps one of the
greatest mistakes she could possibly
make however the question remains what
would have happened had siri actually
taken the mutagen it's clear that there
are no female witchers that occupy
karamorin would siri have become the
first
while at karamorin tris uses her magic
to take siri on a trip through a
dreamscape that triss is seemingly in
control of by the end however triss
begins to fear as the visages of people
within the dreamscape actually see her
something that isn't supposed to occur
furthermore siri gets her first view of
the wild hunt a pack of wraiths who
appear as ghostly specters of death upon
horses when the two emerge from the
dreamscape tris fears siri and claims
that she'll destroy everything in fleas
all throughout season 2 many people are
telling siri who she is and what she can
become trista's view was the only one
that stemmed from fear of the centron
princess possibly bringing about the
apocalypse will siri fulfill triss's
fears of death and destruction only time
will tell
frangilla francesca and jennifer all
encountered the woman in the hut who
manipulated them and fed off their pain
in despair known as the voleth mare she
bargained with yennefer to bring her
siri in exchange for the restoration of
her chaos aka her magic yennefer came to
her senses as she bonded with siri and
understood her importance however it was
too late as voleth mayor fed off the
pain and anguish that francesca felt
over the loss of her murdered child
which released her from the hut that the
first witchers had previously banished
her to ultimately it was revealed that
she wanted siri because the princess was
the only one who could return her home
to her own sphere where she shares a
home with the wild hunt while we are
sure to see more of the wild hunt in the
future will we be seeing more of volath
mare as well
the big reveal at the end of season 2 is
that the leader of nilfgaard emperor
emir varem reyes is actually siri's
father dooney who supposedly died years
ago while fleeing sintra the netflix
series hasn't made clear what really
happened to siri's parents but we do
know that dooney is actually emperor
emir emir states his intent of finding
siri but why did he leave her in the
first place what really happened to
princess pavetta it's likely that the
next season will shed more light on amir
and his history between the time that he
was protected by geralt and his present
status as ruler of nilfgaard
there are several questions that now
emerge with the reveal of emperor emir
sure he seemingly abandoned his daughter
for many years but why is he a sworn
enemy of sintra and the northern
kingdoms what does his conquest truly
afford him sentra was the home of his
beloved princess pavetta who he fell
madly in love with he risked his life
for her hand in marriage and they of
course had a daughter after managing to
claim leadership over nilfgaard why then
would he destroy sintra resulting in the
deaths of his mother-in-law queen
kalanthi and potentially cause harm to
his daughter siri in the first season
dooney seemed timid yet honorable he
claimed to have once saved the life of
the king of sentra which granted him the
law of surprise nothing in dooney's
nature ever indicated he was a
bloodthirsty tyrant willing to kill
babies to sow chaos what exactly
happened to dooney after all these years
that turned him into the dreaded emperor
of nilfgaard
series elderblood offered vessemir a
chance at restoring the witcher order
destiny has given us a gift
the key to making more witches
he created his first batch of mutagens
with her help and was prepared to put
siri through the trial of the grasses in
order to fulfill her wish of becoming a
witcher even if it could have
potentially killed her however if siri
ever decided to donate blood again to
the witcher cause they could potentially
create even more will vesemir and his
witcher brothers at karamorin begin
training and finding new potential
candidates for witchers once again it
seems that it's now within their
capability to do so but it may not be
within serious destiny to participate in
the witcher resurgence we'll have to
wait and see what the future holds for
the witcher order in the next season
in the climactic moments of season 2 a
silent assassin kills philip andrel and
francesca's child and in a horrifying
act of vengeance the elves go on a quest
to ridania where they repay the crimes
committed toward them a hundredfold
francesca uses magic to slaughter the
babies of redania in a vile act that
could threaten the standing of the elves
in the world order even further the
birth of francesca's child ultimately
swayed the elves to rebuild instead of
going to war for nilfgaard because of
this their child was murdered so that
once again they become pawns in
nilfgaard's game of conquest but now
they threaten everything they've worked
for by sullying their name with the
actions committed in redania and we
wonder what kind of consequences they're
going to face in season three
geralt and jennifer are two of the most
prominent characters in the entire
series and they're known for their
passionate romance and feelings toward
one another something geralt never
exhibited previously but now geralt is
faced with jennifer's betrayal as she'd
planned to offer siri up to the
deathless mother in exchange for
restoring her magic while jennifer
didn't go through with her plan in the
end the moment still cut geralt rather
deeply
i know i've heard you
yet i can't help but wish you can begin
again
in the end he tells jennifer that he
can't forgive her however he needs her
to train siri and help her hone her
abilities can geralt find it in his
heart to move past a moment of bad
judgment after all he knows what it's
like to feel empty inside and without
purpose if the history of these two
characters has taught us anything it's
that they'll surely find their way back
to each other once again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you